à marciac dans le gers le jazz est dans
le prêt jusqu'au 15 août
au fil des années ce festival jazz in
marciac est devenu le plus important
d'europe
cent cinquante mille passionnés sont
attendus et beaucoup d'habitués de nina
simone kenny barron en passant par dee
dee dee bridgwater cette année un
hommage particulier sera rendu à louis
armstrong par wynton marsalis reportage
frédéric bonnet et blaise grenier
attention le maïs trop prend la parole
c'est lui c'est le nouveau maître de la
trompette
wynton marsalis 39 ans à peine et déjà
statufié ici à à marciac une bourgade
perdue dans le gers qui devient chaque
année jusqu'au 15 août
la capitale européenne du jazz ici
depuis 23 ans et à tous les âges
on vient pour écouter mais on vient
surtout pour improviser
le jazz c'est avant tout une question de
feeling pour le maïs tron tout le monde
possède la capacité de jouer
si vous arrivez à jouer avec ce genre
d'intensité avec tout votre feeling
alors ça rend les gens autour de vous et
heureux de vivre comme je l ai ressenti
lorsque vous avez joué sur la place
wynton marsalis quittent chaque année sa
nouvelle orléans natale pour le festival
de marciac
cette fois il a rendu un hommage
particulier à luis armstrong son maître
qui aurait un siècle
cette année c'est la fin de ce journal
je vous en rappelle les deux principaux